the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie it means I can see everything
everything that's ever happened to
everyone
everything that's happening right now
it's all pieces now fragments I need to
learn to see better when the long night
comes again I need to be ready what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight
discussion video today I want to talk
about bran Starks capabilities now that
he's the new three-eyed Raven this is
something that gray area and I actually
talked about in one of our collab videos
over a year ago but now I want to take
the time to go through some of the
evidence with you in today's video I
only want to use the evidence from the
show because some of these events happen
very differently in the books however in
my opinion I believe bran Stark does
have the ability to see the future like
he said to Sansa in that scene I just
showed you
bran can only see things and fragments
right now but by the end of next season
he will be able to fully understand all
the information he has access to now
before we get started I do want to give
a special shout out to the sponsor
today's video which is raid shadow
legends
all right folks now is the time you need
to forget everything you think you know
about mobile games because one of the
most ambitious RPG projects of 2019 has
just been released and it's about to
change everything raid Shadow Legends is
one of the most immersive experiences
you will find on any smartphone today
and it can only really be compared with
some of the biggest computer and console
titles from the triple-a developers the
best thing about this game is it's
totally free raid has all the features
you'd expect from a top-of-the-line RPG
it has an amazing storyline great 3d
graphics giant boss fights battles and
hundreds of champions to collect and
customize each champion is unique in
their own right and are frequently
updated for balance and competitive play
one of my favorite characters to use
right now is kale from the Dark Elves
now raid is getting very big very fast
so get in early starting right now will
give you a big head start there's also
an upcoming special launched ornament
what crazy prizes go to the description
of this video now and download raid only
through my link to get 50,000 silver
immediately and a free epic champion
part of the new player program courtesy
of the dev team alright now let's get
back to the video like I said today I
want to talk about brain Stark's ability
to see events before they even happen
let me show you some examples because I
know there are still some fans that do
not believe brain can do this all the
way back in season one there were some
signs that bran stark not only could see
events happening in different locations
but he could also see events before they
happened now there are many characters
throughout this story that do have
prophetic dreams but bran Starks
foresight can go even further than just
that this ability started to awaken
after Jaime Lannister shove bran out the
tower window after brain stark wakes up
from his coma he soon starts to realize
his third eye allows him to see things
that most men do not have access to
shortly after Bryan wakes up the same
three-eyed Raven from his dreams begins
to visit him the same Raven that was
trying to lead Bryan down into the
crypts of Winterfell to see his father
this is when he started to get the sense
that something terrible had to have
happened bran then later finds his
brother Rick on down in the crypts of
Winterfell this is one Rickon says he
was having the same exact dreams his
brand how many times have I told you
he's in King's Landing Sansa and Arya he
was down here I saw him I saw him one
last night when I was sleeping
[Music]
both of them were dreaming about their
father getting killed and as soon as
they emerge from down below their worst
fears are confirmed Ned Stark was
executed and this is one of our first
clear signs that bran may be able to see
events before they happen now this isn't
the only example of that happening Bryan
has another dream but this time he can
see Winterfell get flooded by the
seawater and sure enough
shortly after this is when the Ironborn
take over Winterfell
Theon Greyjoy sends his men over the
walls to take the castle which is
exactly what bran Starks dream was
symbolizing once again bran was able to
see an event before it happened only he
wasn't able to understand what he was
getting shown he may be opening his
third eye but he still struggles with
the information he is given because he's
still very young even as recently as
last season we hear brains say that he
needs to learn how to see better he has
to find a way to translate all of his
visions now shortly after Theon takes
Winterfell bran is able to escape bran
eventually has another dream where he
seized a three-eyed raven again this
time brain tries to shoot the raven with
one of his arrows however he soon learns
that he cannot kill the raven because he
is the raven bran learns this from Jojen
Reed who appears in his dream then once
again shortly after brain wakes up his
dreams become a reality he ends up
meeting the same boy from his dream and
it's this boy that will lead brain stark
to the three-eyed Raven that is also
from his dreams now what's interesting
about Jojen Reed is he also has green
dreams just like bran Jojen also has the
ability to see certain things before
they happen but he does not have the
greensight there are some other examples
from the show that I think prove these
green dreams do predict future events
but now I want to move on to some of
bran Starks visions I believe these
visions may indicate some things that
will happen at the very end of the show
I think these visions are some of the
best evidence that shows brain is able
to see fragments of the future only he
has to learn how to translate them as
bran is continuing to travel to the
three-eyed Ravens cave he has Hodor set
him down in front the weirwood tree that
is beyond the wall when brain touches
the tree he is able to see multiple
images at once if you look closely at
some of these images
you can see that some of them are from
the past present and even the future now
let's take a look at some of these
images because like I said I believe
bran was able to see some things that so
haven't happened yet
one of the most important images from
the show is that of the Great Hall
completely covered in snow this is the
same exact image Daenerys Targaryen saw
when she was at the house of the undying
sense brain stark and Daenerys Targaryen
both saw this that it obviously has to
mean something now you could say this is
obvious symbolism for who should truly
sit on the Iron Throne the Iron Throne
is covered in snow and as we all know
Jon Snow is the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne so maybe that is what Dany
and brains visions are trying to tell us
however I think it does have two
different meanings yes it does indicate
Jon Snow is the rightful heir but I also
think it's a glimpse into the future as
and we will eventually see the Great
Hall look just like that we have already
seen snow begin to fall in King's
Landing that started to happen during
the season 7 finale now after the battle
for King's Landing is over I imagine
most of the city will be demolished
Daenerys Targaryen dragons will cause a
tremendous amount of destruction to that
city I think she won't have any other
choice because Cersei will refuse to
give up her seat on the Iron Throne now
let's take a look at some of the other
images from brains vision now as we all
know the night King was not introduced
until season 4 episode 4 however we get
our first glimpse of him during that
vision now keep in mind brain has that
vision during season 4 episode 2 you
have to look very closely but brain does
see the night king where you see is
about the pickup crashed her son from
the ice altar in the lands of always
winter bran is able to see this two
episodes before it actually happens bran
was also able to see a dragon flying
right over King's Landing some say that
it could be a vision of Aegon Targaryen
flying over King's Landing but some
others say it could also be Daenerys
Targaryen flying over King's Landing
now we do know Daenerys did take her
dragons to King's Landing last season we
all saw this happen when Daenerys went
to meet Cersei at the dragon pit now
maybe that's what brand could have seen
in the vision but that doesn't seem very
significant now the reason why I think
this has more significance than just
that is because bran has seen this more
than once
bran also saw the drag
and flying over King's Landing when he
had another set of visions during season
six
now that brain has seen this vision two
different times
I think this scene must have a very big
impact on the story we don't see any
snow on the rooftops when the dragon
flies over top of the buildings but
maybe this could be a scene from the
very end of the show after all the
battles are over and the long night ends
maybe we see the Dragons over King's
Landing after John and Daenerys have
taken the city if that were the case you
would think that some of those houses
would look like they have been burned
down during the battle however maybe
they shot it that way as to not give
away too much information this early in
the show it's hard to say right now but
I would like to think that is another
vision from the future there is another
example of this during the same set of
visions brain can also see the wild fire
exploding underneath King's Landing
now some fans believe that was the mad
Kings wildfire because they did show the
Mad King at the same time but that was
meant to trick us we do know the Mad
King did have wildfire but he was never
able to ignite that wild fire thanks to
Jaime Lannister the Wildfire we see
exploding in the vision has to be from
something else which we later find out
at the end of that season bran was able
to see the Wildfire during season six
episode six but we know that Cersei did
not have it ignited until the very end
of the season therefore bran was getting
another glimpse into the future I think
this might have even happened again
during last season only this time we did
not see it in a vision what I am
referring to is when brain stark gives
Arya Stark the Valyrian steel dagger I
believe brand-new exactly what Arya
would do at that dagger when he gave it
to her now I know I cannot prove that
just yet but something about the look on
Bryan's face makes me believe he knew
what would happen we can see the camera
focus on the dagger as Arya grabs it out
of brains hand the way bran lets the
dagger slip from his fingers is very odd
but I think it's the look on his face
that's very telling it's almost as if
bran knows what he just done now keep in
mind brain knows that Arya is a killer
he was watching her as she was getting
ready to go kill Cersei Lannister bran
also knew everything Littlefinger had
done which is why he repeated the phrase
chaos is a ladder
I think brain knew little fingers
Judgment Day was coming and he also knew
out of
the Starks are there aria was the killer
bran had to have known it was only a
matter of time before he revealed all of
Littlefinger secrets and since he gave
Aria the dagger he must have known she
would have used it to kill Littlefinger
now as we all know bran has told us he
can see everything but it's still only
in fragments right now he's still trying
to learn what all the different visions
actually mean as soon as he learns how
to process all this information only
then will he be able to stop the night
king for good well next season the final
season bran stark will be at the height
of his powers now that the night king is
south of the wall and heading their way
bran no longer has time to train he has
to learn how to fully harness his powers
sooner rather than later
in my opinion bran does not have full
access to the future but I do believe he
can see some of it in fragments like he
said if that's the case then bran might
have already seen what it takes to beat
the night king he might have already
seen how it all ends only he doesn't
know it yet let me know what you think
down below I want to thank everyone for
watching today's video I also want to
thank raid shadow legends for sponsoring
today's video don't forget their link is
down below you can download the game for
free right now anyways I hope all of you
have a great day and I hope to see you
all come back for the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]